Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sam from Minnesota,
Sam from Minnesota. You're on the air.
Oh, hi. Asked my volume. Your volumes. Beautiful.
Speaker 5: OK, do you really think that O'Rorke
is a good gubernatorial candidate for Democrats
in Texas? You know, he had a statewide race in
2018 and lost to Ted Cruz, of all people. And
that was before he told Texans, hell, yeah,
I'm coming for your guns. So I don't really
have another candidate in mind. But so many
people in Texas. Do you really think that was
the best Texas Democrats have to offer? I don't
Speaker 1: know. We talked about this a little
bit earlier in the week when when on the bonus
show the topic of Beddoe running. I think what
Beddoe has going for him are a couple of different
things. No. One, name recognition to some degree.
Now, name recognition can be bad. As you point
out, if he's known to Texas Republicans,
is the guy who wants to take your guns. So
name recognition can be a double edged sword. I
think Beddoe also has going for him that he can
definitely rebut Greg Abbott's failed policy very
well and directly and eloquently and articulately.
But I don't know if he's the best person to run
against Abbott, but I'm with you in that I can't
really think of anybody else. So I'm excited about
the idea that because Abbott's approval is in the
toilet, maybe someone with name recognition
like Beddoe could actually sweep in and do a
good job. Obviously, as I mentioned earlier in
the week, they're going to run against him on,
hey, these Democrats want to take your guns,
forget about the covid disaster, forget about
the electricity disaster. Better was going to
take your guns. I think that could be a problem.
But I don't have any better ideas right now.
Speaker 5: That's fair. The other day you were
talking about how you felt the interviews
of families of antitax people who died of
covid felt really exploitative.
Speaker 1: Sometimes they do.
Sometimes they do. Yeah.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Well,
I've thought a term of that of a term for that
kind of thing. And I want to know what you think
of it. Yeah. VACC flirtation, that exploitation.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, the thing about it is
that could mean exploiting people who did get it
or who didn't. I mean, it's not super precise,
but it's not a bad idea. I kind of like it. Yeah.
Speaker 5: Yeah. It's just a play
on the old blaxploitation films.
Speaker 1: What about anti back exploitation.
Speaker 3: Maybe it's
getting a little long, it's a
Speaker 1: little too long. Yeah, I think you're
right. I think you're right. Yeah, no, I mean, so
do you agree that sometimes those interviews feel
a little exploitative and, like, disaster porny?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, it's just the
nature of, you know, these new shows
that are looking for content. Yeah, they're.
Speaker 1: All right. I appreciate the call.
Speaker 5: Oh, sure, sure. I was about to ask
you if you think we'll be back to normal amid 22,
Speaker 1: but I think we'll be back to
normal by 32. No, I have no idea. I don't
know. I hope so. But who knows? I think it's
going to be around a couple of years at least.
Speaker 5: Sure, thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you for the call,
appreciate that. Let's some let's speak to some
other people, because there there is really a lot
of people here who want to get on. Let's go next
to Aleesha from Cancun, Mexico. You're on the air.
Hello. Alicia, Alicia from Cancun, you're on
if you're on mute, will be able to hear you.
And last opportunity for Alicia, Alicia from
Cancun, you must unmuted to speak to me,
otherwise the tubes won't work. All right,
that's too bad, let's stay in Cancun and
go to Eric from Cancun instead. Eric, are you
on the air? Hmm. Eric from Cancun, you're on.
Wow, something must be going on with the
Internet there in in Cancun. Let's go next to
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly. Is it
is Sean from Amherst. Yes, that's correct. Hey,
David, how's it going? It's going well, thank you.
Speaker 3: Thanks for picking up my phone call. So
my question to you is, on Sunday, the
parliamentarian, Elizabeth McDonough, ruled
that the Democrats can't include all the
immigration provisions in the reconciliation bill.
Now, the Senate majority leader, Chuck Schumer
and Dick Durbin, they're all being like, oh,
we have a Plan B. We're going to go back to her
with another proposal. My question to you is,
why are they begging it an elected official? Why
can't they simply overrule her or ignore her? I
know that in 2001, Republicans did the same thing.
They probably fired the parliamentarian when
millions of lives are at stake. Do you have any do
you know, like why they're just, like, not playing
hardball and just like ignoring her altogether.
Speaker 1: Ishant? I agree with you completely.
This notion that now is sort of like just assumed
to be true, that the parliamentarian just gets
to decide. I challenge that. And I've read a
couple of good pieces arguing that you don't
read. It's sort of like by tradition that the
parliamentarian is given the ability to weigh
in on these things and that times have sort
of changed. And that, quite frankly, I mean,
this term has a negative connotation, but
they could just steamroll the parliamentarian
if they wanted and then deal with it later. Let
Republicans say I'm against it because it's out
of order. Right. Or whatever. But I completely
agree with you. And I think it's ridiculous
the way they're handling the parliamentarian.
Speaker 3: But do you think there's any chance
for Joe Manchin Kristiansen in mind to have in
the Senate that they're going to even think about
bringing the bill with the provisions on the floor
and let Kamala Harris just ignore her ruling?
Speaker 1: I don't I think it depends on the
bill, to be perfectly honest. I'm not sure. I
think it depends. I think there may be yes.
I'd have to think a little more about that.
Speaker 3: I thank you so much, David,
thank you so much for taking my phone
call. I don't know if you remember,
but like I call last year, too,
I would talk, but yeah, probably not.
Speaker 1: But remind me, are you in
Amherst, Massachusetts, or Amherst, New York?
Speaker 3: Amherst, Massachusetts. I go to UMass.
Speaker 1: Oh, you do? Oh, my God. I just
heard three hundred and fifty positive
cases last week at UMass.
Speaker 3: Yeah. There was like a party in
an off campus gathering townhouses. Yeah. Honestly
speaking, if I'm gonna level with you, I've
stopped caring because there's nothing I can do.
People of no party left and right. Yeah. I can't
help it. It's like there's no point like thinking
about it, just like it just is not conducive to my
own well-being. I cannot focus on those jobs.
Speaker 1: I totally sympathize with that.
Which which townhouses was the party at
Speaker 3: the townhouses which
is like in Sunderland.
Speaker 1: Oh those town. Oh wow.
Speaker 3: OK, ok. Yeah yeah yeah. That
was like a mass congregation and I feel
like there's nothing I can do that that's going to
change to drive the numbers one way or the other.
Yeah. So what's the point of stressing out about
it. I'm fully vaccinated. I take care of myself.
I just like, I'm just moving on. I just
like live my whole life. Whatever happens,
happens. I can do anything at this point.
Speaker 1: I understand. Sean,
it sounds like you're doing all
the right things anyway, so. Yeah.
Thank you so much, David. All right,
pleasure. There's Sean from UMass,
my undergraduate alma mater.
Wow. What a call. What a call.